في ثاني يوم من زيارته للرياض عقد الرئيس
الصيني شيجن بن محادثات معقده السعوديه
تكللت بالتوقيع على اتفاقيه ثنائيه
بمليارات الدولارات بين القوتين
الاقتصاديتين الطمحتين لتعزيز تقربهما
وذلك رغم موقف واشنطن الواضح وتحذيراتها
المتكرره من تصاعد نفوذ الصينه
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه والصين وحرص
على تفسير جميع الامكانيات بتلك الشراكه
اللي مستويات اعلى الرئيس الصينيه التقى
خلال هذه الزياره بالعهد السعودي الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ووقع بحضور ولي العهد
غلام اطلق عليها بالاتفاقيه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله من بين ما تنص عليها تنظيم لقاءات
دوريه بين قاده المملكه والصين كل عامين
ونقلت وسائل اعلى من صينيه قول شيء ان
التعاون بين الجانبين له افاق مستقبليه
واسعه مؤكدا ان الصين تنظر الى الجان
ساعديك قوه مهمه في عالم متعدد الاقدار
ويشارك الرئيس صيني خلال هذه الزياره في
قيمتين خليجيه صينيه وعربيه صينيه يحضرها
قاده دول المنطقه الذين بداوا بالفعل
بالتوافد الى العاصمه السعوديه التي تسعى
الى تنويع تحالفاتها الاقتصاديه والسياسيه